so werewolf by night is slated to appear
in the marvel cinematic universe and
those are words that i never thought i'd
say over the course of my life
never in my life did i ever think that
we would see jack russell
in the marvel cinematic universe mostly
because he hasn't been relevant in 20
years
so it's gonna be kind of weird to see
what they end up doing with this
character now having said that
how do we know that werewolf by night is
going to appear in the mcu okay
so it recently came out that kevin smith
had a conversation with jeff
loeb at a previous point in time those
of you guys who don't know what that
means
back before kevin feige ran everything
under the umbrella of the marvel
cinematic universe and even marvel
comics to a degree
that originally you had kevin feige in
charge of the movies
and jeff loeb in charge of the tv shows
and the idea here
is that kevin smith wanted to launch a
howard the duck tv show
and use basically all these 1970s
characters these characters that
basically belonged on the island of
misfit toys just didn't quite fit in
anywhere and there was just something a
little off about him you know what i
mean just a little
i don't know if i'd watch a show with
that character by themselves that kind
of a thing
but jeff loeb's response was no the
movie division is going to be using
werewolf by night
and that's how we know now again that
recently just came out like
within the last couple days so this is a
huge revelation here now when the time
comes that werewolf by night is actually
given a full-fledged announcement
we'll do a full-on 25-30 minute long
video over comics explained
breaking down the entire comic book
history of the character assuming we can
make it that long because honestly
jack russell doesn't have a whole lot of
history but what's the quick and dirty
on werewolf by night who is this guy
so let's wind the clock back on marvel
comics for a second and jump back to the
1970s
see in the 1960s because like spider-man
and fantastic four and captain america
return all that kind of stuff
marvel could publish anything and it
would basically sell by the 1970s that
hype train had gone away
and so just because they published
something didn't mean that it would sell
and so what they started doing was
basically trim jacking hopping on
popular trends and then making
characters based off those trends so if
you look at luke cage he was based off
the blaxploitation era
black hollywood essentially characters
like blacula you guys ever heard of that
guy
one of the best movies ever in the
history of hollywood i love that movie
blocula is amazing but then you also had
shang chi and iron fist who were based
off the kung fu hype of the 1970s
and then they tried to tap into the
horror genre didn't go as well as you'd
hoped but we did get werewolf by night
so remember the discussion that we had
previously where we talked about how
marvel would release anthology books
marvel premiere
different things like that well marvel
spotlight was another example of that
right and that's quite exactly what it
sounds like which is
marvel spotlighting a particular
character or a group of characters
werewolf by knight appeared in marvel
spotlight number two back in 1972 was
created by jerry conway
now the funny thing about this is we
didn't really get an origin for werewolf
by night until his solo series with
issue
15 written by roy thomas and the funny
thing is that you end up learning that
he is actually the result
of a family curse that it all goes back
to a guy by the name of
gregory the
great-great-great-grandfather of
werewolf by night
and grigori was a guy whose wife was
killed by dracula so he stormed the
castle of dracula drove a stake through
his heart
then dumped his body and his coffin in
the river then he freed a girl named
lydia
lydia it turns out was actually working
for dracula and she herself was a
werewolf
lydia bit gregory and that's how he
ended up becoming a werewolf now the
funny thing about this was that gregory
already had kids
which meant there was no way for him to
pass the curse of the werewolf onto his
family
through the bloodline instead it was
passed on through a family curse
but all this changed when it came to the
father of werewolf by night a guy by the
name of
gregory now the whole thing behind this
is that gregory got his hands on the
dark hole you guys probably remember the
dark hole from wand division that was
the book that you saw towards the end of
the series
and the book that wanda was reading at
the end of the post credit scene at the
final episode
but the whole thing was that gregory got
his hands on the dark hole and in doing
so
activated the curse of the werewolf
within the family genealogy
and so realizing this had happened he
basically sent his wife and his two kids
to america
where their names were basically changed
that instead of it being jack rusoff as
it was in russia or transylvania
instead it was jack russell and so when
jack turned 18 years old
the curse basically fell upon him and he
became werewolf by night in the sense
that he only turned into a werewolf
at night during the full moon which i
feel like is kind of a redundant
statement
when have you ever heard of a full moon
in the daytime but the important thing
here is that following that point in
time
jack russell had a few different stories
here and there but none of them were
super interesting
one of the more interesting things that
happened to him though is he actually
became part of a team
called the midnight suns the midnight
suns were awesome it was basically like
the horror side of marvel comics
with a little bit of doctor strange
thrown in as a singular team it was
awesome it was a great concept and of
course we are supposed to be getting
that in the marvel cinematic universe
so it would make sense that they would
do that if i'm being honest kind of
sidetrack here from werewolf by night i
think what they're gonna do
is they're basically gonna create the
secret defenders in doctor strange two
and then go from the secret defenders
into the midnight suns with like blade
probably johnny blaze or maybe danny
ketch or possibly even robbie reyes as
the ghost rider
robbie reyes is the one who played the
ghost rider in agents of shield
but like some version of the ghost
writer character werewolf by knight and
then
somebody else who knows what they're
gonna do probably michael morbius from
the spider-man film
but regardless of the situation like
we're supposed to be getting that team
which i think is gonna be awesome
but for werewolf by knight himself the
big question you have to ask here is how
are they going to handle him like it's
one thing to say like yes the movie
division is going to use him
but it's another to ask the question
how's it all going to unfold because
this was a statement made by jeff loeb
some years ago before
everything fell under the purview of
feige back when you have like the
netflix tv side and then you have the
marvel cinematic universe movie side
now it's all one so like everything is
under the purview of feige so we don't
know if it's gonna be one of these
things where werewolf by knight appears
in a tv show
if he has like a cameo in the blade
movie or if he gets his own movie unto
himself
if i'm a betting man i think it's too
big of a risk to grab a character like
werewolf by night
and just throw him into a movie that
costs 300 million dollars to make
that's a huge gamble especially when it
comes to a character that's so
incredibly obscure
but at this point after everything
that's happened in the mcu
just the name itself right the marvel
cinematic universe could be enough to
just send people flocking to the movie
theaters to see that film
especially if the trailer looks cool i'm
not 100 sure that's the case
because if you look at black widow for
example it kind of bombed in the movie
theaters but a lot of that's because
people were watching it at home on
disney plus right hence like the big
beef between movie theaters and disney
at the moment but
i don't know if that'll really be the
case if i'm a betting man here only a
couple things are gonna happen with the
introduction of werewolf by night either
he's gonna show up as a cameo in a tv
show
or he's gonna get a tv show unto himself
because unless the tv show is using
you know massive special effects that
cost a fortune like they did in loki or
wand division
it's gonna be a hell of a lot cheaper
than a two three hundred million dollar
film
that may not do that well at all right
it could entirely be a huge bust i mean
granted
iron man was a painfully obscure
character to anybody who didn't read
comics and look how well that movie did
right so just because the character's
obscure does not mean that it won't
succeed
same thing with black widow and even
hawkeye pretty much anybody that was
part of the marvel cinematic universe
lineup in the beginning
with the exception of like thor the
incredible hulk in captain america right
nobody really knew
anything about anybody any of the other
characters that we saw maybe a
passing understanding but certainly not
enough to know their origins or anything
along those lines right and so
i think that where we'll find night
getting a tv show is the best bet here
plus you can do a lot of exploration
with the character and i feel like
that's going to be the future of the
marvel cinematic universe not just for
werewolf by night
but for other characters as well that
you basically treat the tv line
as a way to produce shows that can go
far more in depth with like the origins
of characters
how they became who they were and then
you just throw them into the movies and
you just make a movie based off those
individual characters or like
a big team up or something like that
right like if you look at the x-men for
example magneto gets a tv series
that wolverine gets a tv series
professor x whatever your main lineup is
going to be or
the most prominent members of that
lineup and then when you get to the
movie it's recruiting time and then you
get the plot and the story so on and so
forth the movie ends and then that's
basically it
i think that's the future of the mcu if
not for everybody
certainly for the more obscure
characters i think loki got a tv show
because he was just so damn popular so
they knew people would go and see it
but nonetheless with somebody like
werewolf by night i think it makes a lot
more sense to make a tv show for that
character
let people kind of ease into the
character let the hype build itself if
the story is good enough if the show is
good enough itself
and then in turn throw him into the mcu
like i said the only alternative to that
is to basically have him have a cameo in
the blade film
maybe like blade needs help facing off
against these vampires he knows that
werewolves are the mortal enemies of
vampires and so he in turn
basically grabs werewolf by night grabs
jack russell and the two of them go and
fight some vampires it's kind of a
team-up film to a degree but only at the
very end or at one point in the film
so you still get that kind of treatment
about eric brooks and how he became who
he was
but at the end of the day having
something like that something that kind
of eases people into the character
seems like a far more financially safe
bet than just
throwing out 300 million dollars to make
a movie about a character that nobody's
ever heard of
and that people might not care about
because the reactions on social media
already
are like i don't even know who this guy
is like why like weird you know it's
like that's weird that's kind of strange
people are confused they see it a little
bit odd now
that confusion can turn into interest
which could turn this into a
you know billion dollar movie i have no
idea if that would be the case or not
but regardless
it's one of these things where at the
very least seeing werewolf by night in
the mcu
just seems awesome i love the idea
because again one of the things that
we've seen just by virtue of loki
and wandavision and all those things is
that this era
of the of the kind of baseline marvel
cinematic universe format which is to
say strip down heroes like iron man
captain america to a degree the
incredible hulk thor and just kind of
teaming up to fight against some
threat and a basic plot that's largely
gone right like the earthbound heroes
fighting against some earthbound threat
that's basically it right there there's
there's really no more going back and
doing that anymore right there's no more
ironman fighting obadiah stain there's
no more captain america fighting the red
skull that kind of stuff is done
that instead we're focusing on much
bigger things now
right loki literally brought back the
multiverse
it literally gave us the multiverse
doctor strange is going to be running
throughout the multiverse doing what he
can to keep it contained
wanda is now a multiversal character
right like she's on the same power level
she was
during the events of house of m the
ability to just kind of transverse the
multiverse and presumably
control it on a whim right i mean it's
huge now right the landscape is
massive and so while we may see kind of
a return to that familiarity
i don't think we're going to see it for
a while instead i think it's going to be
a lot of just kind of
out there zonkey crazy stuff and i've
been telling people that for a long long
time
there's a person in reading marvel
comics for 25 years one of the things
that you learn
is that when it comes to the marvel
cinematic universe they've not even
scratched the tip
of the tip of the tip of the iceberg by
all standards of measurement the marvel
cinematic universe has taken its first
steps onto this mountain
even despite what you've seen in the
last 10 years like
it's just taken its first steps onto
this mountain in terms of the villains
that exist out there
the different heroes just on the x-men
side you've got thousands of mutants to
work with
and that's just the x-men right like you
can make movies
just focus on the x-men for 200 years
just tie in
everything else right like the avengers
non-avengers teams
secret defenders young avengers avengers
academy
the initiative program there's all kinds
of things that you can do right project
wide awake all that kind of stuff
i mean it's it's crazy
it's crazy how long they can make movies
for
if when the when the time comes the
marvel cinematic universe ends
it will not be because they ran out of
content it'll be because people got
tired of watching
that's basically what will happen right
like they could make they can make
movies for a thousand years right
it's crazy how much content is there
especially when you take into account
how long it takes to make a movie right
like
release four movies a year it takes a
little while to do that so nonetheless
you know kind of back on track here
we got severely off track here i know my
little my little tangents could be
entertaining at times
but back on track here werewolf by night
is gonna be a great addition to the
marvel cinematic universe if they do it
correctly
and that's what it really all comes down
to if they do it right if the story is
written correctly so
at the end of the day i'm excited let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section let me know if you're
excited as well
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later peace